Rob Reynolds in southern Israel we
earlier we saw a barrage of rockets
coming from Gaza Rob Reynolds is in
southern Israel where we can see the
Iron Dome intercepting those Rockets Rob
tell us what's
happening well I'm here in zakim which
is just a few kilometers from uh the
border with Gaza and over the past uh
say 15 minutes or so we've seen barrage
after barrage after barrage of rockets
coming out of Gaza and then being
intercepted by the uh Iron Dome
anti-missile system the contrails in the
sky and the white puffs of smoke uh
silhouetted against the bless of the sky
are actually from the Iron Dome uh
system they uh arked up very rapidly and
then uh each puff of smoke represents uh
a hit against an incoming missile from
Gaza so it uh it's impossible to tell
really whether any of those missiles got
through but uh this is this is what it
looks like uh in the immediate aftermath
and uh the the story behind this is that
uh uh that Hamas said uh earlier today
that at 5:00 which was when the missile
started that they were going to uh uh
begin firing on the city of ashalon and
they said that in retaliation for Israel
hitting uh uh residential areas in Gaza
they were going to uh give the people of
ashalon uh an hour's warning so that
five 4:00 local time that came out 5:00
local time the we started hearing the
bangs and the and seeing the
anti-missile measures being taken so we
don't know if any of these missiles
actually made it to ashalon but ashalon
has been hit many many times before in
this conflict and in previous uh Gaza
versus Israel conflicts uh it's it's not
very far uh from Gaza and it's a major
industrial city um so so that's what's
happening right now and um you know it's
certainly uh is certainly a dramatic
site when you see these these contrails
arcing through the air at that top speed
otherwise in this area I can tell you
that we've seen an R seeing uh many many
uh military vehicles traveling on the
roads sometimes tanks sometimes uh
transport Vehicles carrying large shells
artillery shells sometimes just uh uh
Jeep type vehicles uh loaded up with
Israeli Army uh soldiers uh but there's
a lot of activity around here and there
are a lot of uh Israeli military uh
Assets in in this area and surrounding
Gaza so uh the big question of course is
what's happening next will there be a
ground Invasion certainly looks like
that's what it's shaping up for
otherwise uh why would Israel be uh
staging all these hundreds of thousands
of troops around Gaza um the problem for
Israel one of the problems the country
has many in this situation but one of
the problems is that by concentrating
all or so much so much of its military
might on Gaza uh Israel uh may
be facing a multi-front war as Hezbollah
becomes more restive in the north and
people in the occupied territories of
the West Bank began uh uh resisting
resistance efforts more more strongly
over the recent days ever since the uh
Gaza War started so not seeing any of
those Rockets anymore but I would bet
you we're going to see some more pretty
soon well we will certainly be keeping
an eye on the scene in Gaza and indeed
this the scene where you are as well Rob
stay with us in a moment because I just
want to explain uh to our viewers what
we're seeing on our screens now it is a
boat that's on fire it's been hit by a
rocket or by an air strike by artillery
perhaps this is just off the Gaza Coast
I remember Gaza is a strip that's Bound
by water it's some 40 km long of coast
Co line and there seems to be an
enormous boat that's been hit there and
that is causing huge plumes of smoke
from the fire that is exploding from
that having been
hit we're going to go back to Rob he's
just uh come under Fire from rockets
that were fired from Gaza they were hit
they were intercepted by the Iron Dome
so he could see them overhead in the sky
none he believes where he has at least
got through in other areas it may have
done so Rob the israelies the Israeli
military for a couple of days now have
asked people in the Border areas to
evacuate there's also been reports that
volunteers have been given arms what is
the what's the civilian population doing
them well um most of the civilian
population is completely uh shocked and
and stuck by the in infiltration of uh
Palestinians uh fighters from Gaza over
the weekend on Saturday so many of those
people uh have left at the request of
the army and it's not really a request
it's more of an order so they're they're
trying to get as many people out as
possible so that they are not In Harm's
Way and don't become uh victims of uh
inadvertent uh uh shelling or or firing
from either side I can't really speak to
that vessel you're seeing off the coast
of the Mediterranean but I will tell you
that uh both ashalon and ashdod which is
just a few kilometers north of ashalon
these are major ports uh and a lot of
the goods that come into Israel come
through those ports so uh if if in fact
this was uh a missile or some other
attack uh
that Hamas managed to pull off against
an international ship that's going to
have consequences because uh shipping
requires Insurance uh insurers are very
reluctant to send to to Ure ships that
maybe going into Harm's Way we see that
in the Black Sea for example in the
conflict between Russia and Ukraine so
uh this could be quite a serious
incident uh it could at the very least
you know raise the uh price of shipping
into Israel and at at at if it were to
become even more severe some shipping
companies might decline to um uh pull
into Port here at all uh but that that's
that's to be seen uh we still don't know
exactly what happened to this ship but
we'll we'll have to find out soon enough
um that's that's about all I can tell
you about that situation but as far as
the civilians yes and the civilians who
who were here uh who were in the uh the
settlements that were uh attacked and
the the kabut and not to mention the
thousands of young people who were at a
dance rave party that was attacked by uh
uh forces from Gaza these people are uh
remain incredibly
traumatized and they know many of them
family members have been taken captive
and been brought back to Gaza so that uh
compounds the anxiet to an almost
unimaginable degree okay Rob Reynolds
joining us there from zakim in southern
Israel just to remind viewers of the
pictures that we're seeing we believe
this is off the Gaza Coast that 40 km
stretch of
Coastline a big ship a big boat on fire
there has been struck by air by an air
strike we're also seeing other enormous
splashes around it as if it is
continuously being targeted we don't
quite know what the target is but we do
believe that is off the Gaza Coast it's
unusual for us to be seeing pictures of
a strike on a vessel in the water so
we're going to be keeping an eye on that
and bringing you more information on
exactly what's going on there as soon as
we get it we just a little earlier
before these extraordinary pictures we
saw other extraordinary pictures which
was a barrage a huge barrage of rockets
being fired from Gaza towards Southern
Israel